there's the list of the individuals who
have agreed to attend the nfl draft in
cleveland three weeks from tonight
others still contemplating their offers
include justin field zach wilson and
turd ferguson one guy who has said yes
caleb farley former virginia tech
cornerback spoke to chris sims yesterday
here's some of what they talked about
how do you
define
a
successful day like at the corner
position when you're on the island all
the time i mean i know you want no
catches but that's not always realistic
so like how do you kind of define it you
know baseball one for three hitting 300
hitter wow you're pretty good uh you
know what how do you see it
uh a successful day for me man is um you
know one most importantly is if the team
wins
um and and two you know i put i like to
see um
you know
i like i like to frustrate guys i like
to i like to make guys know that they
was defeated you know um you know i
don't i don't like it to be a question
at all um you know after the game
i i like for a guy to be able to you
know say you know he got the best of me
i got to do better next time i don't
want it to be any argument or any any
debate of a good battle
you know that stuff just kind of ticks
me off and it always has
um so uh you know and i don't i won't
ever lose that chip on my shoulder all
right guys all right so like what are we
talking to like during the game do you
let them know about it when they're
having a bad day are you are you are you
chirpy out there
yeah i i definitely um um talk um i'm
not really like a vulgar trash talker or
anything like crazy like that but i'm
definitely you know playing mind games
and saying clever clever little
statements and stuff like that just you
know um
letting the guy in front of me know that
i'm confident that you know you're gonna
have to show me something crazy you know
this isn't normal
i'm not a normal corner so
i'm i'm definitely letting guys know
who they're playing against
if a team is is
is looking to take a corner and they
worried about me coming back to the same
uh
type of type of ability man i'm i'm
telling you that's a
that's a that's a question that they're
gonna have to really sit down and pray
on because you know i truly know it's
it's literal risk for you know a huge
reward because
um and it's not the other way around um
you know
so i just have to not get frustrated
about the situation yeah and you know
and trust and trust in god and i kind of
you know um and i like i like how you
know it's kind of like a hidden gem
because i've always been underrated i've
always kind of been that diamond in the
rough out of high school um um so you
know i'm i'm still gonna be me you know
well i i mean yeah that's what's odd
about your situation i i have a hard
time thinking that anybody's going to
watch film and think you're not the best
corner in the draft i really would have
a hard time i mean at least i know my
friends in the nfl think that and all
that but like yeah you got some weird
situations as far as like you're talking
about the back you know the opt out all
that like so like are you
in your heart
do you feel like again i don't want to
like make news here or anything but that
that all that could hurt you to a degree
that maybe you don't go as high as you
should just because of these questions
that are surrounding you
absolutely yeah you know i'm i'm never
gonna be no no no dummy you know i know
i i know i know what's at stake that's
why i said it's a humbling experience to
be able to come enter into your dreams
and to be recognized you know um
you know as the best corner but you know
probably probably not going to work out
that way um you know we'll see it's up
in the air but at the end of the day
you know time will tell you know your
football career doesn't end um
on the draft um so
but best believe you know any team to
take a corner on me just being who i am
with the tip of my shoulder you know i'm
a dog yeah that's going to teach me
y'all that's going to tick me off i'm
going to try to do them like like randy
moss did them you know when they when
they let him fall like that's going to
that's going to take me i'm going to try
to high step all the way to the end zone
you know with the ball in my hand and
pointed my back when i get in there you
know
that's the type of dude i am
that was caleb farley virginia tech
cornerback you know
the injury becomes an issue i first i
got i gotta go ahead it's all right we
we we got we got we gotta work on caleb
farley's background
i gotta do something i got on him and
that's why i encourage people to like
watch the watch it because he was great
we really got off topic a few times and
had some funny things we talked about i
talked about the closet i was like come
on man i mean the first thing all the
hangers just like hanging straight up we
got to work with that he kind of was
like yeah yeah i got to work on that and
then i don't know if anybody caught it
there too there was some feet movement
on the bed there too which i call them
out for at the end i just said i don't
know i said just whoever thinks they're
hiding over there in the bed we saw them
there's somebody there we know that he
was great just the way a corner should
be confident you know strong-willed uh
one of my favorite you know rookie
interviews i've ever done
and hey look i i don't care who's in his
bed yeah caleb let the person sleep
whoever it is
yeah go somewhere else right
and you know i i the one thing i don't
like about the zoom reality is when
people use those backgrounds that are
just
clearly
fake
awful fake and the head movements
but sometimes there's a reason for it
that yesterday
a reason for it caleb farley but seems
like seems like a good guy it seems like
it was a good sport about that so you
can check out chris sims on okay so the
injury issues with farley
uh
how does that impact i i'd go as we
talked we talked last segment about the
the incomplete nature of the medical
information does it affect him i i i
would imagine it does i mean even he
thinks it's going to a little bit you
know and he opted out you know he he
knows there's there's people have looked
at him to go
well maybe he doesn't like football you
know we had that here we go we had that
conversation he answered the answer
totally correctly like a grown man
should be you know first off he said
yeah do i regret it a little bit yeah a
little bit of course but you got to
remember at the time the information
wasn't quite what it is now and you know
there's another aspect again to where we
can't judge these situations they're all
different you know his his mother did
pass away as a freshman in college you
know and i believe she did pass away
from cancer so man that's in his brain
he'd probably going away i don't want to
get my dad sick and lose him too or
something like that so there there's
more to these situations than just this
guy wants to play he's a baller this is
this is jalen ramsey this is he is when
i don't use this
i do not use this phrase lightly all
right this is this is you've probably
never heard me say this
the dude is a generational talent he is
i've never seen anybody six two the size
he is and move the way he does at the
corner position it's as good as i've
ever seen since especially since i've
been evaluating tape and out of football
and doing that it is he is definitely a
top five player in the draft but i think
he's probably gonna fall out of the top
10 because of some of these questions
so where do you think he goes where does
he land gosh i mean let's let's can you
put up the graphic nicole there i mean
you know again the the cowboys at 10 as
far as the draft picks uh not that one
the draft picks the cowboys at 10 have a
need
at corner so that certainly could go
there you know that that wouldn't shock
me you know the eagles at 12 would they
start to think about that i i don't know
you know but it might be farther down
the road you know as you get into the
20s or something like that where he
might fall he is an unbelievable island
i'm gonna lock you down type of guy um
but it's gonna be about that team that
just has a a a real need at the corner
position
and then probably like a randy moss is
gonna be like wait he he was a top three
player on our board we're picking you
know 21 or 20. we got we got to take him
that's it we feel pretty good with the
medical stuff and all that so it's to me
he's one of the mysteries of the draft
but he's definitely definitely a top 10
pick as far as talent is concerned a top
five pick if a cuda's three caleb farley
can be one that's what i'm trying to say
well there's a team there at number 14
who has a head coach who number one
knows a lot about defensive backs and
number two
had a revolving door of not very good
ones last year and they've done what
they have to do to upgrade the position
it'll be interesting to see what mike
zimmer does if farley's on the board at
number 14. because uh right uh if he if
he
maybe just like with moss 23 years ago
it's the vikings that pounce after a
slide like that ends
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports